the leading universities establish
investments vehicles like mit stanford
berkeley and uh yeah well like listen
guys this is what's going on around the
world
leading universities creating a vc now
why are they doing that i guess
there are two main reasons welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring upwards labs and
hillel at stanford academic institutions
are no longer just for academic papers
in research
they are now investing and are deeply
involved in the tech ecosystem
meet nimrod kohen the managing partner
of tel aviv university ventures
nimrod is a serial entrepreneur and
investor he is the managing partner at
tau ventures the tel aviv university
investment vehicle
previously he was a partner at plus
ventures nimrod has participated in more
than 60 investments in portfolio
companies over the past eight years
in companies such as bring yotpo wsc
sports
cmajn house party coreologics and more
nimrod coin good morning welcome to my
show how are you
good morning all good happy to be here
i have to say that i love the office
from the family pictures to the marshall
to the drinks
it's it's a beautiful office are you in
the tel aviv tel aviv university
ventures office now
yes yes it is and i guess this is pretty
much
uh reflects uh who i am you know i
haven't thought about it but once you
are brought it up
i guess all the way family music drinks
having fun exactly i love it i love it
but but really there's another big part
of you that we're still missing from
here which is the
basketball player part guess what so big
of course
you start your career actually as a
professional basketball player today
you're the chairman of a polygamous gun
right
and a team that you've been following
for many years tell me a little bit
about how you how you get started with
basketball and and then we'll have to
figure out this
weird transition into you know serial
entrepreneur now
one of the one of the top early stage
investors in israel so so
i have to understand this whole rundown
well i'll try to understand together
with you let's see so
uh actually i started to play basketball
when i was like six years old
you know as a kid just playing around
with my friends
one thing led to the other i focus uh my
entire childhood on basketball i was
sure i'm gonna make it to the nba you
know it was back at the 80s 90s you know
michael jordan
uh stuff like that so i was sure i'm
gonna make it to the nba
and uh well obviously
never happened but uh uh i i
never say never named never say never
well i'm not saying actually i give up i
give up
not going to happen so i
i i took championship with blind and one
of the leading
high schools there in israel and i was
sure okay things are going that way
that's the only thing i'm gonna do in my
life i'm not gonna work like in a real
uh
real job i'm gonna make millions out of
basketball
i went to a special unit at the army for
like uh four athletes when they
basically do close to nothing and
allow you to continue play basketball
somewhere around that i realized that
okay i'm not gonna make it to the nba
so maybe it's a good idea to think about
some alternatives
but i was i played basketball okay so i
was like okay so let's continue play
professional basketball
let's make a living out of it but let's
combine it with some other stuff so i
studied uh
law and business and actually it was
kind of fun when i'm making nice money
while my friends are going being
waitressed and stuff like that you know
uh
uh so i felt like uh you know that that
what fine for that uh period of time
and uh after i did my uh internship
uh i started learning business the idc
and then i did my internship during my
actually during my uh my internship i
started my first startup but it was like
i wasn't aware that i'm starting a
startup actually
um one thing led to another i had a
friend he was focusing on
he was an expert on the stock exchange
and
stuff like that and uh so we created a
website here in israel
and without business plan without
thinking how we're going to make money
out of it it was just like some
fun and uh it was kind of successful i
mean we're talking about 2005 2006
and we sold it after 18 months so
i was like well that's nice i mean you
invest small amount of money
you smell you said you sell it too much
uh for much more
i'm on to something right i mean how can
people go through it's a great model
and uh and actually then it was like a
unique situation it sounds like fun
because i mean
so we saw the companies but it wasn't
like a huge exit it's not like okay
now you can relax and retire uh
uh it helps us buy our first apartment
which is
great and uh and i'm happy about that
but
i need to have a job i need to pay my
bills and stuff like that but on the
other hand everyone expect to you i
don't know to do something huge you just
saw your first kind of
company i got a phone call from the idc
now it's time to give back and stuff
like that because they were like uh
sure that they were uh yeah so
for four for four years or so i was kind
of
not sure what is it that i'm doing i was
involved with several startups
at least this is what i told myself and
and the others
i practiced yoga like four times a week
something like that
now i guess i guess it sounds like well
that's like the
perfect thing that you can do or you're
about 30 years old you practice yoga
four times a week you just sold your
company
that was now i can tell you that that
was the worst
period of my life when i when i when i'm
really
yeah i guess because i have to
understand that
i guess you are 30 years old you are in
the beginning of your career
you look around you see everyone's doing
like the right stuff
okay so the guy in the high-tech uh got
a
is a bigger car now because he got a
better job
and the guy that went to the low frame
just got a raise and get some more money
and and everyone's doing like the the
regular paths
and you're like okay what is it that i'm
doing i mean uh
what am i am i entrepreneur am i uh
a lawyer i'm not sure honestly
and uh so i was doing that for about
four years
and uh i was lucky enough that one of
the startups that i was involved
went pretty good and uh and we sold as
well it was a little bit bigger again
not a huge thing but it was nice
and uh and then uh i really believe that
most of the things that happened to us
in life happens by coincidence it's so i
mean we have plans and stuff like that
but at the end of the day i don't know
you get
to know your wife because you decided to
go to that bar and not that bar and
stuff like that
um so my brother met uh this guy
uh that uh is a uh experienced uh
investor here in israel and he's his
friend and he met him and he just told
him that
listen we bought an incubator we're
looking for someone to manage their
income better and to become our partner
at the class ventures
so my brother asked me do you think it's
something that uh might make sense for
you so i was like well i have no idea
what it means to be an investor because
with my startups we never raised money
so i was like well let's meet him so uh
i met him and his partner newby and
after two days we decided listen this
makes sense let's work together
so all of a sudden i became an investor
you know i had no idea what it means uh
actually um so i was there for five
years at plus ventures
everything that uh i know actually i
learned from from duby and yossi are my
partners there
we invested in about 40 companies during
the period of five
years uh some kind of successful
companies like house party youtube
uh wsc sports uh semester
logics you know you actually youtube
that was our
first investment now it's like a really
big company i've always said that
we need to stop there after the first
investment you know
we had like 30 of the company we were
the first investors we had 30
of the company wow yeah that's uh
unbelievable
that's that's crazy so that was uh
that plus uh plus ventures uh period for
five years i had a lot of fun
and uh then i got the situation that uh
i was invited to miami by tel aviv
university
there this conference in miami they
called it connecting to ecosystems in
miami connecting the miami ecosystem in
the israeli ecosystem
and they invited me to uh to talk about
so uh you know that's an easy decision
to go to a conference in miami so i was
like yeah of course why not of course
and so i went there and uh after the
conference that the guys from tel aviv
university
they uh told me that tel aviv university
really uh wanted to do
the next step in terms of uh innovation
entrepreneurial stuff like that
and they're not sure what to do so we
started to think of that together
and that you can i can talk for hours so
you feel free to stop me uh i
i can listen for hours at this point so
please keep going
yeah so uh um i realized in the u.s
there's a huge trend where the living
universities establish investments
vehicles like mit stanford berkeley and
so on yeah listen guys this is what's
going on around the world
leading universities creating a vc now
why are they doing that i guess
there are two main reasons first so many
great things going on around those
universities you know among students
alumni technologies they have
great brands so they attract the entire
ecosystem and so on so
you have uh an advantage of recognizing
great stuff before others and on the
other hand
right invest in someone you have a huge
university behind you you can offer your
entrepreneurs much more than money you
can offer them everything around the
university from
the great brand connections the open
doors knowledge
uh workforce offices just emitted
it's an endless list so they were like
okay that sounds
that sounds a good idea go for it good
luck
so the idea was
and actually the toughest part was to
create an
entity that works well around the
university i don't know
how well you know university this is
very uh usually
very bureaucracy uh type of
environment and at the end of the day if
you want to invest early stage startups
i mean
you you can't have biopsy you can't have
long processes you can
you know stuff like that so i was happy
enough that the university gave me like
uh
um actually everything we needed and we
created this entity tower ventures which
is
fully independent we raise money from
investors from all over the world us
canada most of the money is coming from
japan
and uh and the gp the general partner
basically it's a new entity that we
created the uh
fully uh owned by the university and the
partner of the university and uh
at the gp so we act like a regular vc in
terms of
carry you know the return that we get
management fees stuff like that they're
going to measure us by the returns that
we create to our
uh our investors but we have all the
benefits of having a university
with us as i mentioned before so that's
uh
that's the that's the main idea and uh
the idea with our ventures to invest
early stage couple of thousands of
thousands of dollars in each company
really open and wide in terms of field
of interest we are not doing stuff that
requires a lot of time and money to uh
get to the market like uh medical
devices pharma and stuff like that other
than that we're really open and wide
um usually the first check have to have
up to a half a million dollars
so we've been around for a little bit
more than two years we invested in 17
companies so far
um so far so good we are about to uh
raise our next fund in the coming
months or so we're happy to support
entrepreneurs i mean
uh part of our agenda is to uh create an
ecosystem not just being a vc that gives
money and
expect return but to create an ecosystem
around us
that includes not only that we invested
in by the entire ecosystem
uh to bring the industry as close as we
can to create this triangle when we have
entrepreneurs academy and industry
um so usually now it's corona days it'll
be different but usually there are like
tons of people around every day here
that we try
uh that we try to help and to uh uh
create a real uh real value in the
ecosystem because we see that there's a
little gap
uh these days uh there are many great uh
funds are really great funds that raise
like 100 100 plus million dollars
usually they write checks of somewhere
between two to five million dollars
um there's a lot of competition there
there's a lot of money there
but if you are like a little bit earlier
than that and you need like uh to do
like a million dollar round
million point five you need someone to
lead or to follow with the five hundred
thousand dollars or so
there are not that many players around
so we try to fill up
uh this gap uh here and as well we're
doing the best we can and i hope
i don't know i hope we're doing an okay
job
wow nimrod so many thoughts that i have
already so first of all i i want to go
back and
you know reiterate on this idea of the
of you know the coincidences and you're
saying that at the end you know you can
you can plan as much as you want
and there's obviously the famous saying
i don't know if there's also in english
but i know in hebrew you can laugh you
can you complain all you want but then
god laughs at you
at the end right but then but you know
this mentality and this
you know behavior of just accepting you
know the different opportunities that
are presented to you whether it is
you know meeting doobie at plus ventures
and saying okay well you know two days
later yeah let's go and i'm gonna become
an investor teach me whatever you can
teach me
and then going to miami and saying you
know what actually there's a cool
opportunity here
and and getting that approval and
running now with tao ventures and and
i'm constantly seeing the amazing work
that
the tao ventures is doing and pretty
much every every early stage
entrepreneur that is starting out is
talking about how ventures and how
it will be an amazing partner to have
and i recently also spoke with
laura smolyer from there from berkeley
who runs their their vcn catalyst over
there and
and i mean it makes perfect sense i mean
you you're working at an institution
you're both a vc
that has all the perks that a vc can
provide but you also have the university
backing you which is not just
you know a good brand it's no it's
knowledge it's expertise it is
it is different resources it's different
you know academia academic people that
are really great thinkers
and and and more than anything i mean
you have access
to really brilliant minds within and you
know the
the due diligence process can turn from
you know this
five meeting arena to now okay well
we've been following this to it and we
can see we can talk to the professors we
can see what what they're like
and you have much more insight what is
some of your process
as you go and talk to these early stage
entrepreneurs because it's really early
i mean first check
right i mean some of them this is the
first time some of them at cereal what
is sort of the mentality that you go
into this
the this conversation figuring out okay
is this the person that i really want to
trust
you know in this five to ten year
journey now as a first check investor
well that's a an easy and tough
question because i can give you like a
10-minute speech of
all the checklists that you need to have
uh
in a team or founder but i can be honest
and tell you that this is just something
that you feel after a minute
in a room you know it's pretty much like
uh
any other relationships that you have in
your life
and after a minute or two that you talk
to someone actually sometimes you don't
really have to talk you just i know
there is something around the
in the air you feel that if this is
someone that you want to spend some time
with you want him to be your friend your
wife your uh uh whatever it is
and uh i think at the end of the day
it's pretty much the same and then you
try to set up the facts that are
going to be uh like uh accordingly to
your uh your feelings uh so it starts
with something that you just feel
and i can tell you from from the past
that i i've made many mistakes in the
past you know like
when we saw like a great product in a
very interesting field and the team was
like okay so we're like let's invest and
let's help them
maybe in a later stage we replace the
ceo and i don't know it's such a cool
product that we have to invest
it's not going to work never on the
other hand
i can tell you that there are examples
that uh we
we see a team that top top team and uh
the product is like okay and we're like
oh that's that's totally okay because i
really believe that the product is
operated at least in the
stages that we invest the product is
over it yes
because i invested in about 60 companies
in my career
i think none of which is doing exactly
what they they told
that they're about to arrive no it's not
because they're liars
i mean some of them are liars but this
is uh something for another artist
uh it's it's because you know that's
life i mean it's it's unrealistic to
expect that they're gonna know exactly
what they expect before they start the
development before they meet the market
and so on
so first it's something that you just uh
that you just filmed
but obviously there are some checklists
that you need uh uh
that you need to have like the team
needs to cover the the
the core aspects of the of the startup i
mean
uh if it's uh it requires unique
knowledge in a specific field of
technology you wanted to to be part of
the
of the founders you don't want them to
buy it from from the outside for example
you don't need to have a designer
because you need to have a design
website you can buy that
but uh you need to have the the court
stuff
as part of the of the founders you want
to make sure that
there are not too many founders you want
basically each one of them brings
something else to the table and it's not
like they decided to go together because
they are good friends and uh but the
both or the three of them have the same
skill set
uh it's better if they know each other
for a while and not just met like a
month ago
i mean that's sometimes it's okay and it
can work but it's better to uh you know
that
they have some mileage that went through
ups and downs together and uh
uh and stuff like that um again it's an
endless list but at the end of the day
just something that you feel after a
couple of minutes
right neymar i do have to say that i
think that that really i think what
you're saying is is exactly it and i
felt it the same way and i think that
you know the other people that have been
on the show from early stage you know
startups that they they've also have the
same mentality that then it's a lot of
it
it's about the relationships it's about
the intuition it's about the trust
the team that you're presented with is
this the team that you believe will will
make it
you know through this five to ten year
you know marathon
and it doesn't really matter what
they've accomplished necessarily in the
past
three months right because those three
months while they may have some
indication over the next five years
it's really about you know the cohesion
of the team and it's about whether you
you trusted this team
with the seven or 12 pivots that they're
gonna have to make
whether they'll power through them with
transparency you know with humility and
responsibly
and so and i completely agree with with
your outlook and at the end you can give
checklists all you want but again
every team will have a diff will fulfill
a different checklist and you can always
find the right anomalies and
and i think that that's one of the most
exciting things about investing in early
stage companies
you really are a partner of the company
you know sometimes when you invest in
in series a series b series c you know
you're looking at spreadsheets you have
really deep down
analysts at that point really also you
can say okay well maybe it's maybe it's
right to bring a different leadership
maybe now that the company is growing
tremendously maybe the founding team
isn't the most critical part of this
business because you need a business
acumen person
but at the stage you're at it's all
about that person sitting in front of
you with a whiskey or a beer or a coffee
and being able to talk honestly and to
be able to think okay how can we
actually
you know make this a reality nimrod
before we leave i have to ask two
minutes about you know about
apollo ramadagan you're still involved
with basketball how do you combine your
two passions what do you do over there
so uh maybe that's the startup that i'm
most proud of actually when we just uh
re-established a paul ramagan couple of
years ago it was a huge uh
brand here in israel back in the 70s and
the 80s they used to compete with
macabee tel aviv and
they disappeared somewhere around the
80s and a couple of years ago we decided
to re-establish a model with the fans of
the owner of the team so i came back and
played
like michael jordan you know retired
came back to play
and then we went up from fifth division
all the way to second division and i was
like okay that that becomes too uh
uh uh um serious for me again so i
retired and then i became the chairman
of the team for cover field
and actually i felt that uh well that
was
so much fun but it was so hard you know
being a chairman of
a team honestly basically it sucks you
know 90
of the time it's it's the worst thing
that can happen to you i mean uh
the 10 of fun is like most of the time
it covers the 90
but about a year ago i decided okay that
i had enough because i'm a real friend
it's not just i'm enjoying managing at
the basketball team it's not it's not
about that i mean
and because i felt it uh starting to
affect my personal uh
life so i was like this and i i did my
part
let's uh let's give it to others uh so i
step uh step aside a bit i'm trying to
help as much as i can but it's not uh
like
any part of my daily uh routine or so uh
but uh you know of me i mean foreign
not getting to pick your uh your team
it's something that you just you know
uh some sometimes in your in your life
you just got connected and that's it i
mean you're lost
i think one of the biggest inspirations
here is this idea that you're passionate
about something
something is a core part of you and you
just make it happen it doesn't even
matter you know it doesn't matter if
today you're the chairman of before the
being in the grassroots and getting it
going and and making it a reality and
and you know i'm sure that you know that
you know the tens of thousands of
programmer gun fans you know they owe
you a great debt for for just you know
having that
having that charisma and that you know
spot to go and actually make it a
reality and to go and
resurrect it and and i think that that's
really something that is
truly inspiring for me whenever i see it
it's not about you know somebody
offering you an opportunity to say hey
come and do this and then you say yeah
sure but it's about you know saying okay
there's something here that bothers me
i'm just going to go ahead and do it i'm
not going to think too much i'm just
going to go and do it because it's a
part of me and i have to
name it
the most important question that i have
is three words that you would use to
describe yourself
well first read because that's the color
for part of the gun i guess
uh secondly people i really i really
love people and i
like to hang out around people and to
learn from people
and stuff like that and uh maybe the
third
part is fun you know not taking
ourselves too seriously try to have fun
no matter what we do no matter if we're
doing well or not try to have fun along
the way i mean life is too short
i love it and stay tuned and stay
healthy
thank you bye